hello everyone welcome to the
long-awaited round one of the 2019
Greinke chess classic if you remember
last year's winner winner of the Greinke
chest open was a wincenty climber and he
won the green key open tournament with
eight points out a nine I don't know if
you remember if you were subscribed to
the channel back then but in the last
round he defeated Richard report it was
a really an amazing game and he's a
teacher Peter aleko said that even
Magnus Carlsen would be most likely
satisfied with eight out of nine in the
open section and by winning the open
section he qualified for this year's
grant hf classic this is the master
event ten players a single round-robin
featuring players like Magnus Carlsen
Peter Svidler Vishwanath on on
displaying fkd knowledge and a lot of
strong players and the 14 year old the
German superstar as I called him in my
last year's video the German Bobby
Fischer Vincent climber so it's really
an amazing game
it lasted some seven and a half hours I
you know I'm really exhausted just by
watching and I and I can't even imagine
how the players feel after playing such
a such a exhausting game and that we
also do have a surprise but we're gonna
get that after a few moves in the
beginning the tournament lasts from 22nd
to 29th of April and well it's just just
a crazy game let's dive straight into it
as I'm really really tired just from
watching it and it's interesting
Vincent camera is twice as youngest
cousin so Luke Evans and this 14 Carlson
is 28 not very often that Carson will
face such an opponent but okay Vincent
opens with d4 cousin replies with Knight
to f6 we have c4 and Carlson goes for
the Bologna there was a lot to talk
about what opening were will Carlson use
as well he's he faces an opponent who is
twice twice as youngest him and some I
don't know in maybe 300 rating points
lower rated in him so you kind of have
to win because if you draw you lose
rating points and there's a lot of
pressure so d5 advancing the pawn going
into the main line of the benoni g6 with
Knight to c3
b6 and E for now
Bishop to g7 all pretty standard Knight
to f3 and castles by Carlsen Bishop to
e2 and now II five closing up the
position not going for East six so this
is a believe a Czech Benoni we've
castles by climber and now knights ta by
cross and announcing that he is ready to
push f5 at some point with Knight the e1
by Vincente also preparing f4 with f5
pawn captures on f5g captures on f5 and
now Vincent goes for f4 and here there
are a lot of ideas this position already
happened it happened in 1968 in a game
between hunter Kessler and Tigran
Petrosian where Petros and after this f4
move continued with Knight to d7 and
Carlson also goes for this move so he
follows patrols game and in that game
Bishop to e3 was the move but here
Vincent goes for Knight 2 D 3 and it is
of this moment from move 12 that we have
a completely new game on our hands and
since it's only a new game from now I
would like to take this opportunity to
show you a few nice photos and a few
nice high quality videos from from this
event so here we have a very nice photo
of there is the Magnus cross on the
right Vincent on the left and Arkady
dvorkovich the feeder president making
the first move for Vincent you can see
that Carson is already focused on the
game and the Vincent gives cost and the
deadly stare and also we have this very
nice photo
no not a photo this is her a video the
the good people of the Greinke chest
classic video team sent me the these few
videos for us to enjoy
so let us dive straight into it so here
we have as I see the high quality
footage is just amazing there you have
it I've been thinking about the position
Karlsson blurry in the front just let's
just enjoy it for a few seconds also we
have this one also a nice close-up of
Vincent you know pretty stressful
probably for a 14 year old boy to be put
to such a spotlight but as you'll see he
he
very well also here we have a very nice
photo of course and there is see a
blurry Caruana in the background also
thinking what to do about about the
position even though we haven't reached
this position already but I'm sure you
won't mind as you won't be able to
transfer it into the 2d board that we
are using and here the last one from
this perspective there you see a wild
karana appears in the background Vincent
makes his move and well it's just
amazing footage so I'm very thankful to
the bring it just passing video team for
sending us these they're just amazing
but getting back to the game
93 it's a new game from this position
and it didn't whites Crossin to push
efore cross and is no stranger to
grabbing more space in the center so he
does it we have E for forcing the knight
back we have nice to f2 and now crossing
goes for Bishop captures in c3 it's not
a new idea it seems like a very weird
idea giving up your dragon for a night
here but Carson just closed the center
and as you'll see in the position very
quickly
his knight pair will be a lot more
maneuverable than Vincent's bishop pair
so a6 is another possibility just taking
away to be fast where for the night may
be preparing b5 at some point but
caution goes for this forcing line
Bishop captures on c3 be captures in the
now Knight B to f6 or e maneuvering the
nights over to the Queen side sorry to
the kingside Knight g7 is the idea and
the Queen will try to create some sort
of an attack against the White King via
Queen to e8 and Queen to g6 Bishop to e3
by Vincent and Knight to g7 as planned
and Queen to e1 now guarding the c3 pawn
but also the queen is now ready to also
enter the Kings side Bishop to d7 and
now comes Knight to d1 with Bishop to a4
and h3 now and here a Carlsen eliminates
Vincent's night but shall capture some
d1 we have Queen captures on d1 and now
just Queen to e8
preparing to go to g6 to start an attack
and here you can see the center is all
closed up so there are no break through
as possible in the center only
breakthrough is possible in the position
or a6 followed by b5
if carlson decides to do a breakthrough
under on the Queen side or if Vincent at
some point decides to do g4 and well
it's both ideas are a bit risky and
until the mesh repair becomes active the
knight pair will be stronger so think to
have two a Vincent now makes room for
the rook and g1 and he wants to push g4
so he's not afraid of course and he says
I I'm coming for you
Queen to g6 by Carlsen and now comes
Luke to g1 and here came to h8 already
by this point there is moved 21 and
Vincent's been spending a lot of time
which is you know not strange he he won
the the last year's a super tournament
well it's not a super tournament but it
is a very strong especially since he
wanted with a tower nine and now he
faces the world champion in round one of
the main event next year and here he has
to decide that he wants to go for a for
keeping everything stable maybe trying
to create some weaknesses on the Queen
side or does he want to immediately go
for g4 now everyone was hoping he
immediately goes for g4 it's it's a very
powerful idea but it's hard to calculate
it because after Queen to g4 you get
Queen h6 and now you don't really do
much by pushing g5 because Queen h4
check and now after the king knows you
get Knight G to h5 and here if you
capture the night then comes Queen g3
check King f1 and now Queen captures on
h3 with the check not grabbing the best
of it but this check is a stronger King
f2 and now Queen to h4 check King to f1
and now Knight captures back on f6 and
now you have just a very strong position
where white is that material but black
is much better here
so after this g4 move and Queen h6 you
will not be playing g5 you will have to
go rook to h1 and then you get to this
Queen h4 check King g2 and then after
Knight to d7
you can go Quinta you one trade Queens
and then after rook captures you can go
h6 and here you would have this position
with white where where you are a little
bit better but it's hard to decide to do
to play this against Carlsen
and to calculate everything so properly
that that you that you can go for g4 and
that Carlson by playing into h8 and
allowing g4 well he basically says that
this is better for black so here is one
of the moments where events and beliefs
in and he goes for a for and I've seen
the livestream his his teacher Peter
Lego was actually satisfied more with a
for because it just keeps everything
stable not going into anything crazy and
okay look the g8 and here Queen to f1 by
Vincent now if this night wasn't here
Queen g3 would be checkmate you can see
that the Queen and the bishop are not
allowing the White King to move anywhere
so you have to be very careful cars
crossing goes night f2h five now
preparing Queen to g3 checkmate as the
night now covers the g3 Square and here
you have to prevent it so g3 by Vincent
and now rook 8 f8 just bring that rock
into the game
Queen to g2 now and now comes Queen to
f6 attacking the c3 pawn and Vincent
simply defends that we have rook a to C
1 and now you have to again decide what
to do one option is definitely Knight
captures on g3 a piece sacrifice that
follows Queen captures and now nice to
h5 opening up an attack against the
White Queen and now after you move the
Queen Queen to h4 check King to f1 and
now rook captures on g1 King captures
and you want ugh check King to f1 and
then well you have to close up the Queen
side and try and play this position it
looks scary for white but black doesn't
have anything decisive here so by going
for this Carlson would mostly be
offering a draw which Carson is not
interested in after this rotate the c1
cross and just continues playing we have
Queen to d8 now with ideas of maybe
going over to a 5 and attacking the a 4
point and the c3 pawn from the Queen
side so perhaps the idea is to win the
pawns on the Queen side we have Queen to
h2 by Vincente
and now just Knight back to f6 with g4
now and here Knight to d7 and it seems
now that Carson is ready to play Queen
to a5 for
by night to be six and win the pawns on
the queenside
and here we have g5 it's interesting
that after Vincent pushed g5 he had only
six minutes on the clock and he'll he
needs eleven more moves to reach time
control
well Carson had over 40 and here Carson
does go Queen to a5 and this is where
things started to take a wrong turn for
Vincent here you have to go h4 h5 h6 and
only then put g6 at breakthrough and the
king said but vincent immediately went
for g6 his idea is that when cousin
plays h6 which he must the to go Queen
g3 Queen h4 and deliver checkmate but
it's not all that all that easy first we
have looked to be won and now rook to b8
defending this pawn not b6 blocking off
the Queen's retreated d8 square we have
Queen to g3 now preparing Queen to h4
and capturing here but now cross and
just retreats Queen to d8 and this is
the point now that Vincent pulls g6
immediately the Queen now has access to
the h4 square and a Queen to h4 by white
is not possible anymore so we have King
to e1 by Vincent and now Knight the e8
by crossing King to d2 and now tonight's
the f8 here cross and is ready to win
this pawn and we have Bishop to f2 here
Bishop to h5 was also possible taking
control of this pawn but then you then
Knight to f6 attacks the bishop and well
here white just wins so this would have
been possible for white but it's Vincent
is very low on time and he didn't find
this line now of course g7 wins the game
so here after night - a fate of instant
doesn't find this Bishop to h5 idea he
goes for Bishop to F 2 and here Carson
is no rush to capture the point now he
just improves the position Queen to e7
and now the same idea that we already
shown better to h5 doesn't work because
now Knight of 6 is possible as the Queen
covers the g7 square so here after Queen
t7 we have King - III Vincent is just
waiting to see what Carson will do and
now Queen to f6 here
by the point by the time constant late
Queen to f6 he could have captured a
pawn but there's no rush because of
instant has only one minute on the clock
and Carson is pressuring him to make a
mistake Vinson goes King to d2 and only
now let's cross and capture we have
Knight to g6 and now h4 you have to be
careful where you move the knight
otherwise you might get Queen captures
and g8 checkmate so nice the East 7 by
cross and opening up an attack towards
Vincennes Queen Queen to h3 and now Ruth
captures in g1 we have rook captures on
g1 and now Queen to f7 and here this is
move 40 so by playing rook captures and
you want Vincent to reach time control
so here he was awarded additional time
so now he's no longer under time
pressure but the game is highly
complicated and it continues and as you
can see Carson is up a pawn so it's not
an easy position we have h5 by Vincent
and now comes Knight back to f6 Bishop
to h4 and now b6 just strengthening the
Queen side and look back to B 1
preparing to push a5 and to bust open
the Queen side and here cross and goes
Queen to f8 not pretty much any and no
one understood what Queen to f8 was the
Peter Leo and young Gustavson agreed
that the Queen was much more useful on
f7 but here
most likely what Carson was doing and
what they agreed upon was that he was
simply trying to get Vincent to waste
more time and this is the motive instant
us as he doesn't really have all that
many active moves he goes rook to g1
cross and repeats going to have seven we
have rook to be won look the g7 by
Carson rook to g1 by Vincent and Queen
back to f8 and with this few moves the
Vincent is again under 20 minutes so he
constantly tries to see what what Carson
is doing and it seems to be working for
Carlsen King to see two and now Knight F
the g8 re maneuvering the Knights we
have king to d2 and now Queen f7 we have
King back to c2 by Vincent and now rook
to f8 so now the position changed and
any threefold repetition ideas to get a
draw by win
will no longer be possible at least not
for the moment
Vincent goes King back to d2 we have
Queen t8 now transferring call his
attention over to the Queen side look to
a-1 defending the pawn and now rook to
f7 we have a five by Vincent be captures
on a five rope captors on a five and now
comes Knights to see it just defending
the pawn also the rook is defending the
pawn and once this night comes to b6
there will be constant pressure towards
the c4 pawn and it will still be a very
difficult position for Vincent to play
he goes look back to a-1 and now Queen
to f8 we have looked a be one solid rook
to be one and by the time this was
played the Vincent was again down to
five minutes on the clock and here cross
one just causes the B file with Knights
to b6 now with constant pressure towards
the c4 pawn and now rook to g1 and here
everyone thought that constant blundered
because everyone is following the hunter
livestream watching cesses analysis the
the Norwegian supercomputer and hero
says his line was I will show it as it
is
well quite pleasing 8th just a 5 and
after I moved by white a four and now
after rook to be one attacking the
knight Queen to b8 this is the idea the
Queen has to come to the a7 and after
rook to be five a3 King to be one and
now Queen to a7 guarding both denied and
the pawn on a3 after rook to b3 a to
check King to a-1 and now Ruby joins the
Queen side with rook to b7 this was says
explain on how to continue pursuing
advantage with black but Carson tried a
different idea here cross and played
rook to g7 and he allowed the Vincent a
lot of activity and here Vincent
immediately strikes rook at first on g7
King captures on g7 and now Queen to g3
check King to h8 and now Queen to g6 and
this is the problem now cross and can't
move the Queen or the night as they have
to keep an eye on the h6 pawn and also
you can't move the knight because of
Bishop to f6 wins immediately so cousin
has to figure out what to do here we
have a five and now comes
to f1 with Bishop to f1 Vinson reaches
the second second time control and he's
awarded additional 15 minutes
so he's again out of danger Carson
continues with a four with king to see -
and now a three brilliant idea because
and that allows him to continue the game
pushing for some advantage even though
it's really unbelievable that you can
even push for advantage here with the
White Queen tying all of your options up
like this here King Tubby three and now
do you see the move by black that cross
and have in mind even even feel free to
pause the video here to see how you
protect the a3 pawn I'll give you a
couple of seconds if you were very
interested in trying to do it I know
it's late and you must be exhausted but
it's it's a nice idea for those of you
who were able to do it you are an
excellent maneuver of knights and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show
Knight to a4 this is the idea across on
plate because now of course capturing is
the best thing to do but there are also
other possibilities here you could
capture and then play everything that
follows but Vincent here isn't
interested in that you could go captures
and then Knight captures and seater if
you capture the night sorry if capture
the night obviously you cannot prevent
the pond from queening so after captures
and captures on c3 you could now go back
up to h3 going for this but now it's
really a draw pretty much after Queen
eight check King B - Queen B eight check
allowing king after Sun City but now
Queen before check this was Carlson's
idea king c2 Queen captures on c4 King D
123 check King a1 Queen III checked and
now you can't go King f1 because Queen
captures Bishop with check then you no
longer have backup captures on f5 so
here it would have to go back and Queen
d3 check it would be in raw but here an
amazing moment happens Vincent
either didn't find this or he's not
interested in a draw he plays Bishop to
h3 immediately and now he wants to go
for this mating idea Crossin goes Queen
g7 trades Queens we have Queen captures
King characters and only now
or captures on f5 but here Knight to f6
and here a Vincent is again down to his
last five minutes and there are no more
time controls there are no more
additional time givings so you have to
play the absolute best idea and it's not
all that difficult to make a mistake
here here it seems like just captures
captures and captures secures the draw
for white but this was a this would
actually be a huge mistake because a2
now wins the game for black you have to
stop the pawn from cleaning but then
your Bishop is very poorly placed on e4
Knight captures and c3 check picks up
the bishop it's all over so after Knight
to f6 Vincent late King captures on a3
it's the only good move for white and
now the game continues Crossan goes
Knight captures on c3 and here you have
to go King to b3 after King Tubby 392
Bishop captures on f6 King captures on
f6 and virtual captures on e4 with
Knight captures on f4 and then Bishop to
f3 guards the pawn and this position is
now a draw but with two minutes on the
clock
Vincent doesn't find King to be three he
plays Bishop to f2 preventing Carlson
from pushing the passed pawn and gives
new life to the position Carlson goes
Knight to e2 attacks the f4 pawn but now
first King to a for King to a four is
not a great move but it's hard to see
with so little time on the clock why
King Tubby two was better but you will
see why a Vincent went King to f4 he
wants to go over here over here grab
this pawn move the King and Queen the D
pawn but as you see it is quite
troublesome Knight captures on h5 by
Carson and here we have King to a5 you
can't cap you can't capture the pawn
just yet because here you see that the
bishop is again oddly placed because
nice III check picks up the bishop so
here Vincent has to move the King yet
again King a 5 and not Knight back to
have six defends the pawn and now Carson
is again an in game where Vincent is
really down to his last minute and he's
up upon a knight pair against a bishop
pair this is really this is just
legendary King to be
six going for the d6 pawn we have kink
to s7 by Carson and kink to c7 and here
with King t7 Carson protects the base of
his pawn chain and now comes Bishop to
e3 and again it's a very delicate
position you have to be very careful
Knight the d4 you cannot capture or
otherwise you get too connected passed
pawns so you have to move the bishop
bishop to g6 and now comes h5 by
crossing preparing to push h4 bishop to
f2 guarding the h4 square and now Knight
to f3
we have Bishop to f5 now controlling the
h3 square so if Carson starts pushing
the F on that it will not be all that
easy here h4 would actually be a big
mistake for Crossan because the Vincent
would get a chance to go back in b6 and
then he would be able to protect the c4
pawn so Carlsen immediately plays the
absolute best move Knight d2 goes for
the c4 pawn and now you cannot protect
it well you can rush up to h4 by
Vincente pinning the night and now of
course if you capture then you will lose
d4 pawn so here Carlson again goes for
the best move III prepares to advance
his passed pawn now comes bush up to d3
controlling e to now comes Knight to f3
attacking the bishop here and now you
have to capture Bishop captures on f6
was played we have King captures on f6
and now comes King captures on d6
finally Vincent gets his own passport
and but Carlsen goes h4 with two passed
pawns Carlson is Carlson is very fast
we have king to c7 now Vincent is also
ready to push his passport to victory
and it's a very delicate position so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find it the best move for Carlsen
in this position you've been playing for
7 hours already
you don't want to make a mistake here
pause the video and try to find the best
move for black in this position I'll
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it you are an
excellent in-game player after seven and
a half hours of struggle struggle and
for those of you who just wanna enjoy it
show h3 is not the way to go here Knight
to d4 is the move but we're just gonna
quickly show h3 because it's very
interesting if
a ch3 then d6 and now if Knight to d4
preparing 96 check then f5 takes away
the square from the night and now we get
this very interesting series of moves e
to Bishop captures on e2 and now we have
h2 going after this guy and now d7
because now the pond will queen with
check so we have to move the King King
captures on f5 and now Busch up to f3
controlling the queening square Knight
captures d8 queen and now after h8 queen
yes black is up a knight but Queen d5
check and it's very hard to calculate if
you will be able to and get out of all
all the checks so h3 would be not the
wouldn't be the best idea
Knights the d4 this is best because now
this move is immediately met with this
check so there are no problems here here
King to see it was played not allowing
night at the e6 to come with the check
but now we have e to and it was in this
position and move 81 that vincent Kaymer
resigned the game
what if you resign well we're gonna show
it you do have to capture or e1 brings
the Queen into the game so after Bishop
captures Knight captures on e2 now you
get d6 and after nine chapters on a4 d7
right here there's nothing to do you
will get a queen but after Knight
captures keen captures the H point is
simply too fast and and it's a it's a
winning endgame for black so yeah
81 moves against the world champion
really an impressive game and everyone
thought Vincent had at least a draw he
had a better position he was maybe you
know maybe if he if he if Carson had the
white pieces instead of instant maybe
Carlson would have won with white but
here cousin just shown what what kind of
what caliber of a player he is because
it's just just insane how there's really
nothing to do in the position but he
just makes you think there isn't any
waste and then you get yourself in time
trouble and then you survive the first
time trouble you survive the second time
trouble but then finally in the third
time trouble you make an inaccuracy
cross and takes advantage of it
and it ends up in a win so a tough tough
first round for for Vincent Kaymer
against the world champion and he has to
you know rest up quickly because
tomorrow he faces vishwanath honored
with the black pieces but you know
that's that's the beauty of chess that's
what it's like to play with the big boys
and he might have a tough tough time in
this tournament but it will bring him or
not a lot of knowledge and a lot of
experience yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Tony more guitar hadiza Botti
Andre Mario's to the rescue Tucker Co
blood and send her your horse for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous video series
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content we're definitely
gonna continue the donut HS classic and
if if there will be time we'll will be
doing a couple Blanca Saga in between
games and for the end of the video let's
once again check out this very nice
photo of Vincent giving Carlson the
stare this is just just a very powerful
photo so you know later let's just enjoy
it for a few seconds more
well there it is I do hope you enjoyed
it have an excellent rest of yours
arrested what day is today I don't even
know I have an excellent rest of your
Saturday and I will see you soon